(spring bounces)
- Woah!
(laughter)
That was fun.
[Retro Music]
- [Farra] Growing up, we
had a lot of conflict.
I did not like her until she was
wait how old were you
(Dinging)
when you went abroad?
- 21.
- 'Til she was 21.
- She's the angry one.
- I'm the
No you're the,
(laughter)
she's the angry one, I'm the passive one.
- We're both laid back but
I feel like we could both be
- We could be
aggressive.
- We could both be, yeah.
- I have never been in a physical
fight besides pulling her hair
and poking her and annoying her.
- I've been in a physical fight.
- It's usually like if
a guy says something
to me I'd like punch
him but then he's like
'Oh, you're a girl I'm not
going to punch you back'
so like that's kind of how it went.
- These people would throw peanuts at me
'cause I'm allergic
- Oh, okay.
- And I picked him up by his
shirt and I threw him down.
- See, aggressive.
- If anybody is frustrating anybody,
I'm probably frustrating her.
(laughter)
- But I don't get frustrated,
so it's totally cool.
- That's true.
- I think we're playing a game
that will help me not
hate her all the time.
(swoop)
(ding)
- [Jade] Oh my God, I'm so nervous.
- What?
- What is this?
- What the hell is this thing?
- Jabi. Jabi!
- Jabi?
- Oh my God I love it.
- This has huge arm extension.
- I'm gonna assume it's some sort
of punching, for sure.
- Yeah.
- This could really hurt somebody
- Yeah, like please don't
punch me in the face.
- I'm gonna win.
- No you're not.
- Did we purposely put
the black and white one?
- Wait, look at the size
of this guy's helmets.
All we got is a little thing
- Yeah, we don't have
we got this little headband and they got
head gear.
- They have a full on
head gear in this photo.
- Oh my God.
- Oh, you're joking me
You're joking me.
- How do you feel safe?
- Like this, is this right?
- What, that's smart as heck.
- Oh my god, wait.
- Do you feel safe now?
- Yeah but I can't hear.
- You don't need to hear,
- Okay
- I'm just gonna punch you.
- I hope you go home like
that to your husband.
- This is gonna what?
- This is getting weird, guys.
This is a different level
of intimate with Jade, here.
- This is like years of like aggression
being taken out right now.
- I don't wanna hurt you.
- I'm not gonna hurt you either.
Okay, soft.
- Okay.
- Here.
- You're getting crazy.
- Oh, sorry.
- What just broke? Okay whatever.
- Okay, lets continue
- Okay.
- No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
- [Referee] Knockout!
- I feel invigorated.
- Yeah, so do I.
- I'm huffing right now.
- One minute.
- One minute exercise
and I'm already dead.
- Did I win?
- No.
- I definitely feel like this would be
a bonding experience, we
wouldn't do this normally.
- There's a slightly like weird
sexual innuendo to this thing.
- 'Cause it's like a you know
- Yeah, it is.
- Definitely resolved some
of our conflict in our life.
- Yeah, because nothing resolves
conflict like a penis to the face.
- Ice cream solves any issue.
So, you gotta problem,
just get some ice cream.
Then you won't have any problems anymore.
(retro music)
(swish)
(creak)